digamos que queremos calcular la masa de
un núcleo de helio 4 verdad y primero
necesitamos descubrir qué es lo que hay
dentro de ese núcleo así que si tenemos
un número atómico de 2 entonces podemos
decir que tenemos dos protones verdad
ahora bien si nosotros le restamos el
número atómico al número de masa que en
este caso es 4 entonces obtenemos 4
menos 2 que son 2 verdad es decir
tenemos 2 neutrones en este núcleo
así que si conocemos la masa de un
protón y la masa de un neutrón entonces
podríamos calcular fácilmente la más
esperada de un núcleo de helio 4 verdad
y la masa de un protón en unidades de
masa atómica es decir en un más es igual
a la masa de un protón verdad la masa de
un protón
1.00 7 2 7 6 4 7 muy bien pero nosotros
tenemos dos protones así que necesitamos
multiplicar este número por 2 verdad
vamos a multiplicar este número por 2 y
veamos qué es lo que obtenemos podemos
sacar la calculadora y escribir 1.007 2
7 6 4 7 y lo multiplicamos por 2 y nos
da 2 puntos 0 145 52 94 muy bien
entonces esto será igual a 2.014 55 294
y por supuesto esto está en unidades de
masa atómica muy bien ahora vamos con el
caso del neutrón el neutrón tiene una
masa de 1.000 86 64 90 verdad todo esto
está dado en unidades de masa atómica y
nuevamente tenemos dos de ellos así que
hay que multiplicar por dos y que es lo
que obtenemos tenemos 1.000 86 64 90 y
lo multiplicamos por 2 y eso nos da 2
puntos 0 17 32 98 así que vamos a
ponerlo estos dos puntos 0 17 32 98 y
otra vez estamos en unidades de masa
atómica y finalmente si agregamos estos
dos números y los sumamos podríamos
obtener la masa del núcleo verdad así
que hagamos esas cuentas verdad
simplemente vamos a sumar estos dos
números usando la calculadora verdad
tenemos ya este número que le podemos
sumar el número anterior que era 2.0 145
52 94 y obtenemos 4.0 31 88
274 muy bien entonces lo escribimos
tenemos 4.0 31 88 274 y esto está
nuevamente dado en unidades de masa
atómica lo que nosotros hemos obtenido
aquí es una predicción de lo que es la
masa de este núcleo ok entonces digamos
esto es una predicción es la predicción
del valor de la masa del núcleo de helio
4 aunque la masa real del helio 4 verdad
el núcleo de helio 4 ya se ha medido
experimentalmente y no es exactamente
ese número en realidad es 4.00 150 608
unidades de masa atómica muy bien
entonces este valor digamos es el valor
real el valor que se ha obtenido
experimentalmente así que puedes
observar que hay una diferencia aquí en
realidad no es el mismo número verdad es
en realidad el número predicho es más
alto que el número digamos real de la
masa así que vamos a calcularla
entre estos dos números verdad lo que
tenemos que hacer es simplemente restar
los y que es lo que obtendremos bueno
aquí tenemos 4.0 318 82 74 que es el
valor de la predicción ya este número
hay que restarle 4.001 50 60 8 muy bien
y obtenemos el valor de 0.03 0 37 666
muy bien ponemos 0.03 03 76 66
nuevamente unidades de masa atómica así
que esta es la diferencia entre estos
dos números verdad el valor predicho y
el valor real y es a este número al que
le conocemos como defecto de masa este
es el defecto de masa esencialmente es
la diferencia entre el valor de la
predicción y el valor real del
la masa del núcleo de helio 4 y en
principio uno pensaría que hemos perdido
masa verdad aquí hemos perdido masa y en
realidad es lo que ha ocurrido esta masa
de la digamos el defecto de masa lo que
ocurrió es que se convirtió en energía
para que se pudiera formar el núcleo y
eso es algo muy muy interesante verdad
de hecho podemos calcular cuánta energía
digamos se liberó de acuerdo a la
ecuación a la famosa ecuación de
einstein verdad que relaciona la energía
y la masa y que de hecho es la ecuación
que la mayoría conoce verdad sabemos que
la energía es igual a la masa por la
velocidad de la luz al cuadrado muy bien
donde por supuesto la energía está dado
en jules la masa está dado en kilogramos
y se es la velocidad de la luz verdad
así que esto estará dado en metros sobre
segundo que por supuesto vamos a tener
que elevar después al cuadrado muy bien
así que vamos a calcular la energía con
la que estamos trabajando en este
ejemplo vamos a utilizar la ecuación de
einstein
y vemos que nosotros necesitamos
kilogramos y en realidad nosotros hemos
calculado la masa pero en unidades de
masa atómica verdad en sumas así que lo
primero que tenemos que hacer es
convertir estas unidades de masa atómica
verdad a kilogramos y de hecho en un
vídeo anterior hemos mencionado y como
es cómo tiene que ser el factor de
conversión entre unidades de masa
atómica y kilogramos así que vamos a
hacer un poco más de espacio por acá de
hecho sabemos que una unidad de masa
atómica es igual a 1.660 54 por 10 a la
menos 27 kilogramos muy bien así que lo
primero que tenemos que hacer es
convertir este número que tenemos acá
arriba a kilogramos así que
matemáticamente como lo hacemos bueno
tenemos que cancelar las unidades de
masa atómica muy bien así que eso lo
hacemos muy fácil simplemente escribimos
0.03 0 3 766 6 unidades de masa
atómica verdad y lo multiplicamos por
digamos 1.660 54 por 10 a la menos 27
kilogramos verdad y esto lo dividimos
entre 1
como una unidad de masa atómica de esta
forma las unidades de masa atómica se
cancelan y sólo nos queda kilogramos muy
bien así que nuevamente saquemos la
calculadora y este resultado que
habíamos obtenido vamos a multiplicar lo
vamos a abrir paréntesis por 1.6 60 54
por 10 a la menos 27 muy bien cerramos y
eso nos da 5.0 441 y vamos a redondear
esto como 7 muy bien entonces vamos a
dejarlo simplemente como vamos a usar
otro color esto vamos a dejarlo como 0
perdón no era cero era 5.044 17 por 10 a
la menos 27 kilogramos muy bien vamos a
confirmar esto es 5.044 17 por 10 a la
es menos 29
-29 muy bien aunque vamos a
a escribir bien esto es -29 así que con
esto ya podemos calcular fácilmente la
energía utilizando la ecuación de
einstein verdad
y con este valor de la más allá podemos
calcular la energía utilizando la
ecuación de einstein simple simplemente
tendremos aquí la masa que es este
número 5.044 17 x 10 a la menos 29
verdad y esto por supuesto estará dado
en kilogramos y luego multiplicamos por
la velocidad de la luz al cuadrado
verdad y vamos a utilizar un número un
poco más preciso que es 2.997 92 por 10
a la 8 y esto elevado al cuadrado verdad
y de hecho estos son metros sobre
segundo esto elevado al cuadrado así que
saquemos la calculadora tenemos sin
vamos a calcular primero 2.99
92 por 10 elevado a la 8 verdad y esto
lo elevamos al cuadrado y eso nos da
este número que lo multiplicamos por el
número de la masa verdad que 5.044 1
7 por 10 a la menos 29 y eso nos da este
número que es 4.533 4600 vamos a dejarlo
simplemente redondeado hasta este 6 muy
bien entonces esto será igual a 4.5 33
46 por 10 a la menos 12 jules verdades
que son unidades de energía que es justo
el número que habíamos obtenido aquí muy
bien entonces esto que hemos obtenido
aquí es la energía liberada cuando se
forma el núcleo que vamos a escribirlo
así esta es la energía que se libera o
la energía liberada cuando se forma el
núcleo cuando se forma
núcleo
núcleo muy bien así que hagamos un
dibujo de qué es lo que está ocurriendo
en este caso bueno nosotros teníamos
originalmente dos protones verdad
tenemos dos protones vamos a pintarlos
aquí tengo un protón tengo otro protón y
por supuesto también tenemos dos
neutrones muy bien tengo un primer
neutrón y otro segundo neutrón quizás
debería ser un poquito más pequeño esto
ahí lo tenemos muy bien por supuesto
para formar un núcleo de hidrógeno de
perdón de helio 4 estos se juntan y aquí
tendremos digamos un esbozo de nuestro
núcleo ya estarían todos juntos muy bien
ahí tenemos nuestros dos protones y aquí
tendremos nuestros
neutrones muy bien y esto en teoría
representa nuestro núcleo de helio 4 y
además sabemos que la energía es
liberada la verdad entonces digamos que
en esta ecuación falta poner la energía
que ya hemos escrito de este lado muy
bien y de hecho esa energía es el número
que hemos calculado verdad es este
número que tenemos acá arriba así que
cuando el núcleo se forma es digamos
esta es una bonita imagen de qué es lo
que está ocurriendo verdad de qué es lo
que está ocurriendo cuando el núcleo se
forma y sabemos que hay energía que se
libera verdad
de hecho el núcleo es estable debido a
esa energía que se liberó y de y de
hecho podríamos pensar también en la
dirección opuesta verdad es decir
imaginemos que tenemos un núcleo de
helio 4 al cual hay que agregarle cierta
cantidad de energía es esta cantidad de
energía a la que hay que agregarle es
cierto de esta forma lo que podemos
conseguir es que este núcleo se rompa en
todos estas en todas estas partes en dos
protones y dos neutrones la energía que
tendríamos
aplicar para romper este núcleo es
exactamente la misma que se libera
cuando el núcleo se forma verdad
entonces a esta energía se le conoce
como la energía de enlace nuclear
energía de enlace nuclear y de hecho esa
energía coincide con esta cantidad que
nos tardamos varios minutos en encontrar
muy bien así que puedes pensarlo de
ambas formas es la energía que se libera
cuando el núcleo se forma y que también
es la cantidad de energía necesaria para
romper el núcleo muy bien en todas sus
partes y tenemos este núcleo estable
pero esto es algo un poco raro verdad
porque sabemos que las cargas positivas
se repelen entonces tenemos estos dos
protones tenemos estos dos protones que
se repelen mutuamente así que debería
existir alguna otra fuerza que esté
manteniendo nuestro núcleo unido y eso
es a lo que conocemos como la fuerza
nuclear fuerte de la cual vamos a hablar
en el próximo vídeo